productivity purgatory
the ancient Greek word for work was not
at leisure a 21st century grind
addiction has turned Pursuits like walks
in nature meditation and time in
sunlight into just another productivity
hack slowly turning all leisure
activities into a tribute to work
yeah so I've been thinking about this
for a long time
um
so basically there's Greek uh sort of
classification of tasks so ancient Greek
classification of tasks they they
divided tasks into tele activities and
atelic activities now telek comes from
the Greek word Telos which means an end
or a gold
and tele activities are activities that
you do in order to reach some goal so an
example of this would be washing the
dishes or washing your car or doing some
kind of chore or a job going to a job to
do your work
and then opposed to this is atelect
activities and atelic activities are
activities that you do for the sake of
the activity itself and not for any
other goal so an example of this would
be
um
anything that you enjoy so painting
maybe a picture if you enjoy doing that
you know I mean that could be both uh
telek because you're doing it for the
love of painting but you're also doing
it to have a painting at the end of it
um so that maybe that's not a good
example so I would say um a tele a good
example of an atelic activity would be
going for a walk in the park or
something you know assuming you're not
doing it for exercise but you're just
doing it just had it well you could do
it for exercise but you're not doing it
to reach a certain destination you're
just doing it to
for the sake of walking you know you're
walking for the sake of walking
and what I've been trying to do in my
life is I'm trying to turn a lot of my
tenic activities into atelect activities
I've got these I've got this I think the
correct terminology for you here uh
autotelic derives goals joy and reward
mostly internally judging their own
actions exotelic derives goals joined
reward externally takes care how their
actions are being judged
yeah I mean I use the words helic and
atelic um
maybe I think they're a bit simpler yeah
and yeah so it's called telicity
um that's the terms that those are the
terms that I use yeah oh well this has
been hijacked by a bunch of like
athleisure companies so it's taking me
all I can see a lime green uh like
slip-on [__] uh no no I think the
best thing to do is I'll just type in t
t e l i c I did I did and it came up
with a bunch of sandals and it will I'll
I'll check it out afterwards so
telekinetallic cool yeah yeah so so I'm
trying to turn
um sort of my tele activities into
atelect ones I'm trying to do more
things just for the sake of doing them
because I think if you can enjoy the
activity itself and not think too much
about the goal uh then you will become
much more you'll become more content
with your life I think I think a lot of
people do things just for some kind of
goal and they don't enjoy the process of
doing the thing that they're trying to
do have you gone as a result of that
they become less they'll become less
good at actually achieving the goal yeah
have you got any advice on how you are
becoming more italic
yeah so I try to find enjoyable ways of
doing things because there are there
usually are there are less enjoyable
ways to do it these there are more
enjoyable ways of doing things so for
example
um I used to hate working out but I've
started working out recently and the way
I've I've made it into more of an
enjoyable activity is that I I listen to
music that I really really enjoy but I
only allow myself to listen to that
music when I'm working out
so if I want a hero tune that I really
really enjoy I can only listen to it if
I'm working out so that compels me to
work out so it makes the process of
working out more enjoyable because I'm
focusing on the music and you know I'm
just kind of like uh just doing that so
little things like that you can just
turn activities into
um into more enjoyable things and also
another thing is when I go for walks for
instance I used to kind of find Walking
boring because I would go through the
same group all this all the time but now
I mix up my roots and I've go down
streets that I've never gone down before
yeah I love doing parks and yeah and
just completely just losing myself
because I'm living in a new area now so
all of this is alien to me the area that
I'm in now so I just basically just
wonder I just choose a direction and I
just go in that direction and then I
just end up at these unexpected places
and I might see some like crazy Cafe in
the middle of corner somewhere and just
that looks nice and just go in there so
you just make a simple thing like
walking far more enjoyable by adding
that element of surprise and the
suspense you know so going back to what
you were saying about how you create
create that suspense for your audience I
think suspense can really help make
things a lot more enjoyable when you
when things are a little bit
unpredictable when you don't know how
they're going to turn out I think
unpredictability is one of the great
spices of life if you can make something
unpredictable then it becomes a lot more
exciting and a lot more enjoyable and
you don't need to take huge risks with
this unpredictability sounds like uh you
know I'm gonna try and make it home on
half a tank of gas even though I've got
200 miles to go or I'm gonna have to
jump out of an airplane or something
like that unpredictability can be as
benign as you want it to be it can be
you know taking a left instead of a
right on the way to work every single
morning for over three years now I've
started my day the exact same way which
is with element in water element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
and it is the best hydration drink that
I've ever found it tastes fantastic it's
super refreshing orange is just the most
OP flavor in the world it's absolutely
phenomenal and it helps to play a
critical role in reducing muscle cramps
and fatigue regulates your appetite it
optimizes brain health and it helps curb
Cravings they're also the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and rely on by tons of
Olympic athletes and everyday High
performers all around the world also
there is a no BS no questions asked
grief and policy where you can buy a box
completely risk-free and if you do not
like it for any reason they will give
you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you'll love it elements are
giving away a free sample pack of all
eight flavors with your first box if you
go to the link in the description box
below or drink lmnt.com
MW that's drink
lmnt.com
MW what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]